hello in a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a man who is outstandingly
talented in two different fields
medicine and music and areas in person
Stefan polish thank you very very much
for joining us today here on talking
Germany yeah welcome lovely wonderful
now chef our village is both a
cardiologist and a conductor and he's
currently taken time off from his post
as the head of Berlin's institute for
social medicine to work as the director
of another highly prestigious Berlin
institution the hanns eisler academy of
music so it's pretty obvious and I I
would imagine you can guess what my
first question will be because there's
people always talk about the it's a
common place the connection between
music and mathematics what is them the
connection between music and medicine
well I think there is there's many
interesting aspects they are both are
based on a highly structured system like
music is based on mathematics medicine
is based on Natural Sciences but then
you need a lot of subjective
interpretation of emotion to bring this
field alive so in medicine you need the
doctor physician relationship a very
subjective intense personal emotional
relationship to make medicine alive and
to support healing aspect and in music
obviously you need you need a
spectacular and emotional interpreter of
that music player so so there's many
similarities plus medicine has profited
from music over centuries so music has
had been used in hospitals quite
specifically the Middle Ages for
specific diseases you would treat with
specific music the this is new to me
yeah yeah well it has become forgotten
because over the development of Natural
Sciences music has played a much lesser
role than in hospitals but now there's a
renaissance going on we sort of
rediscover effects of music and think
about how can be used them for healing
healing processes and so on mm-hmm and
it's not just all about healing for both
of these for both music and medicine
it's also about you can make people
happy as simply as that absolutely yeah
yeah satisfactory satisfaction in life
and and it's very fulfilling many people
use it as a yeah for stimulation and on
whatever level mmm and at the moment
what would you say you are more a medic
a musician or a manager because you've
got three tats on or percentage over
here well my current job is being a
manager I'm the president of this music
conservatory and so my aim and my task
and my my duty is to to develop that
conservatory in the best possible way
and develop it artistically but also
strategically financially in ordered
also with respect to the awareness of
the public and so on
some very interesting footage there of
you in action conducting and what have
you but there was also some lovely
photos of you as a young lad effectively
the one I like very very much was the
one with you on your bike they're all
packed up and ready to go with the straw
hat on what was all that about I'm very
interested in bikes and what have you
sir i I've been lots of bicycle tours
when I was a was a teenager so I was I
was four days and weeks but I was out
there touring Germany doing France Italy
the Alps and so on I found that pretty
exciting and I still like bicycling I
think it's a perfect combination of
really experiencing where you are and
and and and still passing certain
distances so lovely amount of my own
heart tell me a little bit about your
your musical family oh well I come from
a bulls of our background your father
was an tony patent attorney my mother a
teacher but there was a lot of music
going on so my mother would take me in
choruses when I was already young child
and it's given the violin in order to
started as my brothers and sisters also
got instruments so it was clearly a
fostering environment nurturing
environment in terms of cultural
influences I said that that sounds very
good when you use the term fostering
environment because often when parents
musicians themselves that they project
their musical ambitions onto their young
children and this there's pressure
involved that doesn't appear to have
been the case no no I don't think there
was real pressure there was clearly
expectations but yeah but I think it was
a it was a it was a fair balance so i
didn't really feel pressure the first
couple of years were hard playing the
violin and it's not really that funny
but but when it started to become an
orchestral instrument and ensemble
experience i already started enjoying it
then ever since music has accompanied me
very intensely in life and you did you
did go off and and begun begin to study
music and stood guard for a year or two
but then you broke off there and chose
medicine yeah I think on the one hand I
realized that I was not that gifted
musician who would make sky-high Korea
and facing reality in an average
orchestra so I think was a rather sober
imagination and on the other hand music
medicine appeared a very exciting and
interesting field and not is really a
passionate and emotional field but an
interesting field and so that's why I
chose medicine at this point mmm it's
interesting I I have one quote from your
where you see you say music seemed too
valuable to me to make it a
bread-and-butter job yeah yeah yeah I
think that there you were well you
worked very hard to establish yourself
as a top-level medical practitioner you
got master's degrees from the US and
France and what while you were doing all
that you were still practicing music on
a very sort of disciplined and constant
level yeah yeah music has always
accompanied me I have always been
involved in a chamber music particular
string quartet and I've always had some
some projects as a conductor and I was
involved in an orchestra work so in my
leisure time my leisure time was always
yeah filled with with a lot of music
mm-hmm and in 2007 it was the world
doctors Orchestra you were you were very
much you were instrumental in the
founding of the orchestra it was your
project really tell us a little bit
about how it came about well um
originally I had separated medicine from
music quite clearly medicine was my job
music my passion but then I I have met
many many doctors that had had a very
intense musical background so that live
with is to two hats and so I figured why
not why not combine it and why not use
music as a means to express medical
responsibility and that's when I started
this war dr. Zorka so when I
I asked who would be interested in
joining an orchestra with the purpose of
demonstrating global responsibility
medical responsibly donating the
procedure of our concerts for medical
aid projects and making people more
aware that in many parts of the world
health care is just not good at all and
how does it work logistically how do you
do how does somebody get into the
orchestra in the first place how does
somebody get onto your list and and held
you you know how do you rehearse how do
you can bring the people together well
getting in is very simple you just apply
on on the website of the of the
orchestra and then you are a member and
get information as to when concerts are
and so on but the surprising part is
that there is literally hundreds of
doctors now from all over the world from
over 50 countries by now that are
willing to devote their vacation time
and and that make organized their own
travel pay for their travel to come
together now they all receive sheet
music way in a head and they prepare and
then few days five days before the
concert we meet in the cities where we
appear we appear in many cities in the
world and then we work very hard like
droppers are used to hard work that's a
fairly easy and then we give concerts
let's just have a look at some footage
which I think we've got a concert or
concerts that you gave in South Africa
not too long ago here we go just tell us
what we're seeing that yeah this was a
very special concert this was a concert
session in South Africa and it was
special because in South Africa we have
supported Medical Foundation the Temple
Mount foundation for quite a while so
here you see footage from Ellen stone
which is a rural area out of
Johannesburg for Google templeman who is
who you consider could see just now has
been active now for 20 years he built up
a medical care center but and that's a
surprising part he also added dance and
choruses like you see here so he also
explored the possibility to use art and
social projects from
health care purposes it was a very
exciting experience there for all of us
a-- it looks absolutely wonderful like
an absolutely wonderful encounter music
became or took even more sort of center
stage in your life only when a when a
year ago or so you became the head of
the hands i slor' academy of music here
in Berlin how did you get that job I
can't imagine you simply applied for it
well in a way I applied for it but other
people had had hinted that there might
be a good combination and for me I think
it was a once a lifetime opportunity to
to do what I love to do anyway and to
combine my my university experience with
with music as a passion so it was a
surprise for many colleagues of mine but
those who would know me better and for
my friends it was not that far-fetched
this this move and as I said I think
I've I'm blessed and and it's it's a
great job it's a fantastic conservatory
and it's an exciting challenge to to
make that move ahead as a president
let's begin by talking stefan village
about the location of the of the Music
Academy it's right in the heart of
Berlin at the gendarme and marked square
which some people say is one of the most
beautiful squares in Europe it must be a
great place to work in that sense yeah
absolutely fantastic we're on the John
diamond Mart and we have a second
building right next to the Newcastle
that is rebuild now so in the master so
five minutes walk away so spectacular
location right in the heart of Berlin
look at you and that the whole thing is
named for an hands czeisler yeah yeah
I'm sure you can explain or give us an
idea of who hand-sized the was cuz in
Germany's you know it's quite well known
but in outside Germany not many people
will be from I think the general hands
Isis rather unknown he's a nurse and
Austrian composer he was an Austrian
composer we had actually a very exciting
interesting multifaceted life it was a
pupil of schoenberg for his composition
studies he he was successful in the 20s
and 30s and then had to leave because of
his communist background he emigrated to
the US then he had another interesting
stage in his career because he became
known in Hollywood as a film composer or
a movie composer did some branch was
Charlie Chaplin and so before he then
again got her ass there again because of
his communist background and this of his
brother was a clear-cut communist so he
came back to to Europe and to Berlin and
became eventually a professor at the
Conservatory of hands I slow he's his
best-known pieces probably the national
anthem of the former German Democratic
Republic that we have heard at olympic
games and yeah interesting political
figure who explored the interface
between music and society and quiet some
some details really fascinating life
thank you for plotting it out for us
there lies that's great stuff it the
question I suppose that comes next is
the Academy today was a very prestige
institution in East German times yeah
still is how many continuities have been
retained because people from the former
East Germany tend to say well you know
it all got thrown out after the wall
came down the West Germans moved in and
took her over is that is that what
happened at the hands I slores it be
more sort of subtle than that it was not
a drastic turn around music had always
been a rather protected filled with from
a political perspective protected field
in the ears so it was a rather liberal
field compared to it to other sectors so
of course it was a gradual transition
and I think incisor is a very good
almost prime example for the success of
reunification I think you still clearly
have an Eastern influence here but we
have spectacular professors from all
over the world students from all over
the world so be a truly international
institution now and very successful and
high-ranking institution and at the head
of it is you are you viewed as an
outsider being the you know the coming
from the medical profession are coming
from outside the Academy and taking over
at the helm as it were yes I'm clearly
viewed as an outsider and that was
purposely done so the traditional ways
to elect a professor from your own staff
for certain years to become president
but that has pros but also disadvantages
there's always conflict of interest so
having an outsider I think is a sir it
is a clear advantage in moving ahead the
conservatory there's important
challenges now budgetary challenges
strategic challenges also I think our
the focus of our work has changed a
little bit as you could hear already in
the and the footage of the movie I think
traditionally won't addict eight our
students to become prominent solace or
orchestra members but that's not as
early enough nowadays you also have to
give them more advice with respect to a
successful career talking about
marketing skills
marketing skills project skills we also
talked about the value of music for
society and making that more accessible
and valuable so bringing our our
artistic gifts also in also to societies
maybe of for example of a lower
socioeconomic background I think that is
very important now and that's what we
start to do now tell me how good the
Academy is in international comparison
when people will always look to
conservatories in places like I don't
know New York Beijing Warsaw so on where
does Berlin rank well it's hard to
generalize because it clearly depends on
the instrument you may have an influence
extend and then another instrument not
that much but I think in general we
clearly want to be among the leading
schools in Europe and and I think we are
among the let's say ten leading music
conservatories in Europe that's pretty
good going yeah you've got you've got
very good teaching staff just give us a
feel for that yeah I mean we have a have
a number of fantastic people that our
world-renowned artists and are still
very active in terms of their own
concert careers and that of course is
very helpful to attract also most gifted
students from all over the world hmm
you'd be living in Berlin for quite some
time now do you view yourself as a
Berliner you weren't born here well i
was born in southern germany and then
there i spent my youth and then
following my studies i was several times
and as several years I spent in the
United States but 18 years ago I moved
to Berlin and Berlin has become my home
I think it's a fascinating place it's a
it's a lively place it's it's of course
a city with a long and troubled history
which but also a city of extremely rich
and diverse cultural life so no I've it
has become my home and I am
not a passionate Berlin lover but I I
like doing you're being cautious it's
also a city that has an all and an awful
lot of building sites and that's John
thanks to a lot of construction work and
that's chef and village it's been a huge
debate here in Berlin for many many
years about whether to rebuild their own
solemn palace or not what's your
position on that great debate mm-hmm
well in general I think I'll of modern
architecture and I admire the courage of
people and of societies to get involved
in modern architecture in Berlin I think
you generally have a certain tendency to
have more of historic approach so the
castle is is a good example it could
also have gone for a brand new modern
architecture there on the other hand I
think it's a great opportunity and being
the next door neighbor with our building
or conservatory building I think we will
we will clearly seek the options to
cooperate as early as possible with it
with the evolving cultural life in the
castle I mean it's certainly a very
expensive project it was supposed to
cost 590 million euros initially were up
somewhere and now around an estimated 1
billion euros list before we talk about
what they're going to actually do with
and inside the building just tell us a
little bit more about this second
location for the hand size their Academy
that you've mentioned tell us about the
history of that building the second
location is in the what you call marche
de here in Berlin this is right next
door to the castle and it used to be the
building it's a big classicist filling
the building where all the carriages and
all the horses of the Prussian kings
were so it was many many horse many
horses was a huge garage if you wanted
and it's it's renovated in a great
fashion it's really exactly as to our
needs in terms of practicing areas but
also beautiful concert halls grade
officers so it's it's truly a
fascinating renovation of this building
for our purposes and I've mentioned
already 1 billion euros
for the newt for the new building for
the humboldt forum as it's good as it's
going to be called just give us an idea
of what is going to what's planned in
the humboldt forum from what you know
and what role you see for the hands eyes
their academy there yeah well i think
the planning processes are still ongoing
there's no fixed concept yet but clearly
it will will be home for certain
exhibition ethological exhibitions but
also modern library modern libraries and
so on and I think our prospective would
be to also include music as an aspect
here or we also we are planning for a
for medium library of modern media
library in our buildings so that is
something where we could probably
exchange our our models and and be
attractive for visitors in the castle
and in our building so plus them they
have they will have concert halls so
there will be a possibility for
performances there where we clearly will
be involved and so on mm-hmm so that's
all interesting stuff absolutely and
something for me to look forward to but
we saw in that report about the building
site we saw that in recent years it's
been very much a sort of a grassed area
where people have tended to hang out
it's very much what people associate
with Berlin being very very cool you
must have been you must have been able
to observe all that in recent years all
your premises yeah oh and I love it I
love free free space so they could have
left it that way for another ten years
or so from my perspective and as I said
there is opportunity there this there's
big potential also in the Newcastle and
over the next couple of years it will be
it will be ready to go hmm so very
optimistic take on everything from the
from the cool and the culture to deafen
village there now as we've seen chef and
village is currently taking time off
from his other important post as the
head of Berlin's institute for social
medicine epidemiology and health
economics where one of the key focuses
is on what they call complementary or
alternative medicine and
an idea of what that's all about let's
have a look at homeopathy which is as
popular as it is controversial here in
Germany somalia somali boss current or
like cures like samuel hahnemann was a
german physician from Saxony over 200
years ago he created a system of
alternative medicine called homeopathy
it was based on the healing principle
that that which can produce a set of
symptoms can also be used to treat
symptoms take the humble onion allium
cepa it can make your eyes water but by
the same token it can be prescribed as a
treatment for someone who suffers from
watery eyes based in the town of curtain
in eastern Germany hanuman spent years
testing the effects of different
substances to avoid toxic effects he
explored extreme dilutions of the
compounds he was testing he claimed that
when they were prepared according to a
technique of systematic mixing through
vigorous shaking these delusions were
still effective in alleviating symptoms
from the outset homeopathy has been
controversial its detractors believe it
is completely ineffective and that
remedies are often diluted to the point
where they no longer contain any active
ingredients researchers have spent years
on a fruitless quest to prove that
homeopathic cures can be effective so
far there is no scientific evidence to
back as belief that said a survey of
more than 4,000 patients at the sheraton
Hospital in Berlin revealed that many
people said they feel better after
taking homeopathic remedies over fifty
percent of those questioned said the
remedies helped
while some have utmost faith in
homeopathy others dismiss it as humbug
but the fact of the matter is that many
patients say it relieves their suffering
and that is what matters there's a lot
to talk about here yeah Richard Dawkins
the the British the scientist and author
who's very controversial normo seeks
controversy he he he has called
homeopathy the hottest alternative
health fad what's your reaction to that
well homeopathy is a buzzword is a
buzzword where many people fear have
extremely strong feelings right live
fierce opposition and fear supporters
the truth is how myopathy in terms of
mechanisms and in terms of scientific
basis is unexplored we have no idea
what's really going on and but supposed
to go on on an effect level on
observational level I think it is also
obvious for many individuals have
profited from that people were
conventional medicine may not have led
to the success that was hoped for so but
why it works and how and who would
profit most is unfortunately totally
unknown for my personal opinion I mean
I'm a I was trained as a normal
conventional guy some from my own
perspective it's clearly not this this
little homeopathic medication that's
highly diluted a medication however it
is probably more likely this very
intense physician-patient relationship
that is typically it is very typical for
the homeopathic therapy setting and that
may have a very strong influence I mean
it's literally hours that is spent in
intense exploration and communication so
that is time that that you never have in
conventional medicine nowadays when you
talk about conventional
medicine do you understand quite why the
response to homie off the homeopathy has
been sometimes so vitriolic so
aggressive well because the idea that
this highly diluted me that the higher
you delude medication the stronger the
affection it's very paradoxical seems
absurd and for every modern normal
scientist it must be a it must be a sign
of yeah it's just not it's it just
doesn't seem reasonable mmm therefore I
I understand that it's an almost
militant debate with respect to the
value of potential value of of
homeopathy I find it sad because there
and in etiquette because the true
challenge would be to think well how can
you explain effects you know what other
factors are important there as I
indicated the doctor-patient
relationship maybe maybe maybe how my
pathak could be a good entry to start to
explore that in more detail what makes a
good doctor what makes it bad or what
what supports treatment success beyond
pure technology and beyond pure
medication hmm certainly it has its
origins it has its roots in Germany is
there so is this a branch of medicine
that is very German or is it what can
you tell me about where else in the
world it has been adopted and is popular
mmm it it was developed here by a guy
named Hanuman but they then made a big
career elsewhere in the world and UK it
is very it's very prominent you have a
homeopathic hospital and in London which
was reason to rename and you have Prince
Charles was a big supporter for
neuropathy but you have other countries
you have idea where it's very popular
you have United States well in the
United States you won't find every
everything with which sounds exciting
and interesting so so it has supporters
all over the world and that makes it
fascinating it's just clearly not a
German only phenomenon okay dokay and
it's your institute for social medicine
which is attached to the charity
hospital here in Berlin a very
prestigious Hospital it says on your
website we believe that a pluralistic
approach to treatment is the only way to
guarantee that patients receive the best
possible therapy tell me a little bit
more about what that means in concrete
terms the pluralistic approach well
that's very important I mean
traditionally we have the convert
conventional medicine that it's being
taught in university hospitals but then
we have the what we call alternative
medicine or complementary medicine that
many private physicians would offer that
in many patients utilize that whether
it's acupuncture or yoga or osteopathy
or you name it and traditionally
unfortunately there is very little
dialogue going on so usually patients
have the choice either I go to a
conventional doctor or to some
alternative practitioner and I find that
very unfortunate because in medicine
maybe for a cute disorders modern
medicine may be very good but for many
chronic disorders the combination may be
best so our goal and the at the shiit
hospital in our Institute has been for a
long time to to put both fields together
and try to find the best possible
combination for each individual patient
that's what I perceive as an important
goal for the benefit of the patient and
I'd like to ask you whether you yourself
have ever experienced acupuncture
treatment I have experienced it only two
or three times and I have needed it
fortunately so I but we explored that
and examine that in huge studies and in
carefully controlled studies and there
it was surprisingly helpful acupuncture
through so particular for pain treatment
treatment of chronic pain but also for a
certain allergies allergic conditions so
I was amazed about the effects observed
in these studies the reason I'm asking
is because I am a case in point I had a
back strain from from from I was out
running and then I had a back strain and
I went along to my doctor and he
would you would you give acupuncture a
try and I said well d are you
recommending it and he said yes and I
had treatment here on my ear and where
and said that the seventy percent of the
pain disappeared in just a couple of
moments really it was quite astonishing
stuff and presumably that reflects you
know the the broader investigation the
ambulance that's that's a very typical
and remarkable example that's what you
often feel that people that are treated
with only conventional methods pain
medication also usually don't get that
success and all of a sudden you get some
breakthrough and again in acupuncture
nobody really knows about the mechanisms
so far and this is of course a
fascinating thrilling chair challenge
for the future how to how to how to
clarify the mechanisms we're talking
about music and healing we're talking
about the benign impact the music can
have on body and mind you are a very
busy person that much is clear very
disciplined person when you want to
relax what music do you listen to while
I'm a very narrow minded a classical
oriented person so classical music i
think is over ninety percent of the time
is what I what I here within classical
music I'm I'm rather broad I mean
there's clearly some some some some very
important figures from bajo Beethoven
two bombs and Buckner and Marla and so
on that that I'm very attached to but in
general i'm very curious and very
open-minded to any kind of classical
music no mention of Mozart on the
healing effects of music I'm surprised I
think the older you get the more only
Mozart or town that's what colleagues of
mine told me and I I can't imagine that
so when you're eighty probably can't
stand Marla and Wagner anymore but most
artists or let's see let's move on to
our talking Germany quiz at the end of
the show yeah quick questions quick
answers when you have a cold do you
personally choose conventional medicine
or alternative medicine both I like
chicken soups and conquer guy but I but
if necessary agent take the antibiotics
okay what do you prefer conducting or
play conducting who are happier doctors
or musicians musicians and what is more
healing our final question music or
medicine for a cute disorders medicine
for chronic disorders music plays an
important part wonderful thank you very
very much for those words of wisdom that
is your lot with a very talented
thoughtful and thought-provoking step
and village if you've enjoyed the show
as much as I have then do come back next
week and you might like to check out my
blog on the talking Germany website on
the internet there where you can watch
any of the shows that you might have
missed for now bye bye conscious
you